we have discovered parts of in an
internal map that we have in our brain a
map that tells the rest of the brain
where we are in the room or in the world
it's not a GPS almost there are
different types of cells
o'keefe who is the third price we know
he found a typo Sanders complacent which
is active only when animals or humans
are in one certain place we found
another type of cell that fires is
active in many places and those places
were sent is active tend to form
strictly exceptional patterns so the
many locations in the room when a cell
is active form a grid or like a
coordinate system that tells the brain
where we are the animal is walking and
it can be an animal it can be a human
being then you can record with tiny
sensors in the brain and you record the
electrical pulses that are released from
these cells and you magnify them 10,000
times and then we can listen to warm by
one cell and then if we now listen to
one place cell and this is the area
where the animal is walking around this
is the rat and then it's silent silent
silent and then suddenly you start to
hear and then the rat is moving out
again and whenever the animal is coming
back to this place it's the same thing
happening and it doesn't matter how the
animal is coming in from which
directions and the interesting part is
that these places are they are located
in different areas in the environment so
one place L would be active here and
here and so on but then the grid cell
that we found doesn't have one single
active field but it has several ones and
they are separate like edward said like
each field looked like a checkerboard
just how do you say it to the chest yeah
Chinese checkerboard thank you so then
where the marbles should go that is
where the activity field is and we know
that this Chinese checkerboard they have
all these small triangles in between all
marbles and that's exactly the firing
pattern of the grid cells and then the
grid cells come in different sizes and
big fields big distance between the
fields small and so on and this is the
information that goes into the
hippocampus which is the place cell
where Jung don't give Foundation and the
interesting part is that the hippocampus
with places if you lose yourselves in
this structure you cannot remember what
you had for breakfast if you had
breakfast at all and if you lose the
same cells you can't find your way and
environment and the input to these cells
that is the grid cells so the grid cells
are tightly involved in both spatial
navigation and memory